Hey!
Well I just realized I have to be BGM.
Wait, during the starting?
What?
Oh no, no, now!
Now, okay!
I was gonna be like, were you just listening to nothing?
Like, I was like...
I was listening.
Sure, you were.
In my brain!
You know what she was saying?
She was like, what if I just don't turn it off to start?
Like, what if I just never swap off to starting screen.
I was like, wow.
Yeah, you do that.
I was gonna leave you in limbo forever.
Yeah, she hates us.
Yeah.
We're really tired, by the way.
Yeah, hi guys, we're so sleepy.
We're very tired.
We're signing the postcards and we're...
We're doing postcards again, guys.
We're never gonna stop.
This is...
Our original plan was to play on the Switch.
I know, I brought my Switch.
She brought her Switch and everything.
I was like, let's play Mario Party.
Yeah.
And we have 200 postcards to sign.
That's rookie numbers for me.
My signature, because of this pen, is getting bigger and bigger.
So sorry, guys, I have a thick pen.
Sorry, guys, there's like some tech...
Not even technical, some physical difficulties with some of the postcards.
We're doing our best.
And if you're like, why are you signing postcards?
It's for the concert.
It's for Phantom Thief.
Phantom Thief.
We were debating whether or not to tell you guys this, but we were like, you know what, it's sort of obvious.
Like, why we're sort of together other than dance practices.
Wait, what was I gonna say?
That we saw it.
No, I know.
No, hold on.
Never mind.
Oh, I was gonna ask the audio.
Oh, okay.
Can we ask the audio, right?
Yeah.
People are saying marriage because we...
What?
Because you were like, there's another reason we're together.
Oh!
I'm so confused.
Doki is quiet.
I can make us louder.
Because I'm far away from the mic.
Okay, I made us louder.
Oh my god, hold on.
But if we laugh, it's gonna be crazy.
If I laugh, it'll be like so...
That's not fair.
You get the light.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There you go.
Can we push this up a little bit more?
Push it?
Bring it to us?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like I'm a fucking rat right now.
Is that better?
The mic is right in between us.
Doki is just looking down.
I'm fucking signing!
I know, I'm not saying it's a bad thing.
I'm just saying you're looking down.
I'm looking at chat so I can make sure things are good.
You said that negatively.
How was I supposed to take...
Okay, I refuse to sign this.
I'm quickly going on a strike.
Okay, you wanna finish your sentence from earlier?
Alright, so...
The reason why we're here is that we were testing out our 3D!
We were testing out our 3D stuff to make sure everything will be okay for next month.
Yeah, oh my god.
We were also doing our dance practices there as well.
It was so...
It was...
We were...
We were not okay.
Guys, we look so cute though.
I know.
Yeah, we looked really cute guys.
I'm so excited to actually have 3D finally.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I did Soldier Boy.
Yeah, it's the first thing we did when we got there.
Stop, you're shaking the table!
Sorry, when we tried out our 3D.
It was good.
It was fun.
We just been hanging out.
We got back from dinner.
You guys...
Here's another thing that we did.
Mint did Ganon style.
No,
I did not!
I'm no style.
Mint did Ganon style.
Yes, I saw it.
I did Sexy Lady.
Yeah, so we've been dancing.
I'm sore.
I'm like...
Me too.
I think... I don't like the pillows.
They're making my neck hurt.
The pillows?
Yeah.
I sleep with like a specific pillow.
Oh, these pillows.
Yeah, no.
Okay, also guys, by the way...
The showers here fucking sucks.
We discovered something while we were here.
Because we were like...
You just took a shower.
And you were like...
I think the showers are backwards.
Okay, so like...
Mint was like texting us in the group chat.
Being like, there's something wrong with this.
No, that was actually real though.
It was hot.
And then it got cold.
And I had to take a cold shower.
And it was the worst thing ever.
Okay, but then like...
I was wondering.
I was like, wait, you're right.
How come the showers aren't as hot?
I have it all the way up.
I was really confused.
I was like, wait, you're right.
This is weird.
So then I realized...
If you put it all the way down...
Near the off switch...
It actually gets hotter.
But the thing labels was like...
The further up, it's hotter.
But it's not.
I was like, I need to test it on your bathroom.
I went to her bathroom to test it out.
She's like, no, that's not true.
That can't be true.
I just always put it in the middle.
Who puts it in the middle?
I don't want it scalding my skin.
It's not even scalding.
Yeah, the label's misleading.
Any normal person would put the hot at the top.
I don't understand.
It was at the top.
The label said it was at the top.
Mine was warm when I took a shower this morning.
But you put it in the middle.
Yeah, that's the thing.
The middle was where it was hot.
But it was not super hot.
I was confused because I would put it at the top.
I'm a normal person.
Okay.
I'm a ghost.
I'm not a person.
My ectoplasm is literally going to melt.
What do you want from me?
I would be jelly.
I wouldn't even be able to dance.
I thought people liked slime girls.
People are like, don't be normal.
Yeah, but men is not a definition of normal.
You guys know that.
Okay, whatever.
You think that's an insult to me?
No, I know it's not.
I wear my freak with pride.
Freaks, rise up!
She was talking to the technicians at the studio and they were talking about like What?
They were talking about being weebs and stuff and she was with her people and I was full on disassociated.
I think you fell asleep.
No, I was just looking at my phone.
They were talking about their times.
We were like idols and stuff.
Yeah, idols and Japan and everything.
And I was just like on my phone Freaks, fall!
There they go.
We're not sure how long today's stream will be.
Yeah.
Because we're so tired.
Practice fucked us up.
But Dancing in the suits is so different than dancing without it.
So we kept bumping into each other.
We have several duets together and there were times when we would accidentally bump into each other during the thing.
Because we weren't used to dancing next to each other.
We would practice without the other person there.
Yeah, exactly.
So when you meet up and practice and also in the suits we were so uncoordinated.
But we got better.
We figured it out.
We're confident for the concert.
We're so confident next month.
We have a whole month.
What if we forget it?
A whole month without the other person.
Alright, time to bump into each other live!
So if we bump into each other next month then like...
Don't perceive.
Don't even look at us.
Don't come to the concert.
No, no, no.
We need to sell the concert tickets.
Live bumpies.
Close your eyes.
Just if you see anything.
Yeah, if you see anything, you...
Can you imagine if we're dancing and suddenly...
Close your eyes!
No, we mess up and we just see the entire audience just shut their eyes.
That would be so silly.
Don't acknowledge our mistakes.
Also, the reason why we said the postcards might have some physical difficulties is because we were given different sizes Sharpies.
My Sharpie is really watery.
Because we were finally given more than one Sharpie.
And then mine is thinner than hers.
Hers is like extra thick.
Yeah, mine's thick.
If you guys are wondering Wow, Doki, why is yours so thin?
Please don't judge.
No, I think yours looks good.
Don't judge it.
Yeah, but some people like it thick.
The way you looked at me.
Yeah.
The way you just kind of were like
Talking about Sharpies, right?
Yeah.
Why did you say it like that?
The way you had to call me out this morning.
I didn't even call you out!
Actually, yeah, it was someone else that did.
No, okay, so like, you know, like the one of the technicians was like Wow, wow, man.
I can't believe you replied to that.
And then I took a, and then like they showed their phone.
But I was just looking at the mode.
And then I like looked at it for one second and knew exactly what they meant.
And then I was like, and I looked at her and was like, yeah, well, I did you.
And then she was like, it was just a butt, right?
And I was like, no, it's a fucking...
And then I looked at it for one second and processed it.
And I was like, no, it isn't.
I'm tired.
And then she was like, it was the morning!
Yeah, that's so tired.
And then she was like, no!
You know, I'm so sorry everybody.
They're not sorry.
And you know it.
They're like, hehehe.
We got her.
Guys...
You're lucky I'm here you guys you're so lucky because I I swear I swear I swear, I was just like I've been replaced.
I'm never coming back Oh thank god Shut up Shut up Also like before we started streaming She made a Metal Gear reference to me and I don't even remember what she said to me I said I'm gonna put you here with the With the glasses because you're Kazuhira Doki And I didn't acknowledge her.
I didn't even say anything.
I was like, why can't you be a Metal Gear fan?
Like why can't you just be in a Metal Gear?
Why can't you just be in a Metal Gear?
Yeah, and then I was just like not everybody's perfect Only perfect beings like Metal Gear And then I put like, amendment though Wait, if I didn't like Metal Gear I would be perfect?
Is that what you're implying?
No, I'm implying that That I'm perfect?
No, I'm implying that like A perfect person wouldn't judge other people for their lack of references This feels really rich
Um, okay I don't know I'm saying you should... Shut up You should have less prejudice against It wasn't prejudice, it's me just wishing that I had someone else Oh my gosh, Metal Gear Solid 2 is out for 23 years today Yippee!
I think about Metal Gear Solid 2 probably like 10 times a day Daily, everybody You know, I'm just saying When was the 10 times?
Today I literally had my snake out And I was like, do it for him That's one Every time I look at him, that's him That's one And then I thought about it when I was thinking about She had her what out?
Oh my god, you guys are so awful It was a snake It's my snake figure, you guys It's not even Solid Snake No, that is not Solid Snake That's another time There's more than one snake?
Yeah, there's Solid Snake, there's Liquid Snake There's Solidest Snake There's Naked Snake Okay, but which one was your snake then?
Naked Snake But he wasn't naked I don't know Yes, he wasn't, I can bring it up right now Bring it up right now If you posted it on Twitter, I know for sure it wasn't naked I know, but his name is Naked Snake Then what makes him naked?
What makes him naked?
It's his name in the mission Yeah, but why is he called Naked Snake?
Why is his codename naked?
I think it's because they don't give him anything That's not mean He has clothes No, he has no light, oh no, he does have a gun I don't know Oh guys, this is a Metal Gear Solid fan who doesn't know He has a gun I think it's just because he goes into the mission with no shit That's what it is Shame No,
I'm literally explaining it right now You're like, I think, um No, it's literally, I'm literally explaining it right now Alright, alright Fake fan to call you a fake fan No, just because you're fucking Dragoons No, that's not true No, I see a green name saying fake fan I see a green name saying fake fan Shame,
I see some shames in there I literally explained it I can end this stream right now Oh, do it, it's your channel I will, okay, I'll end it Alright, bye everybody Now people watching will think it ended
I would never do that I commit to the bit You're just a coward I commit to bits too, I ban people in my chat I do too Who do you ban?
Name every band You ban your members Do you ban your members?
Do you ban your members?
You're like, I ban people out You ban your members I've timed out members You never ban one, you don't commit to the bit Oh my god Ban Grass right now
I told Grass I would never ban him Ban Grass right now No, I told him That's not the bit It's because I I can't say it I almost said that I like them I almost got him Don't he hate you guys Why, how do I?
You're banning your members, they stole money on you No, no, no, I am bad I am bad, Grass No, no, you put him in it through hell He went through so much hell, he came to my chat To cry about it Okay, but Grass knows what he did Anyway, Mitt I said he wasn't even wrong,
it was so sad No, he was wrong Okay, anyway, Mitt was like You don't commit to the bit Because I was like, I never end stream And then she's like You just don't commit to the bit I've ended stream I was like Are you guys having a good week?
Okay I'm checking in on them We haven't seen them in days We literally talked to them yesterday Some people probably don't have Twitter Yeah, because some people Also, because you forgot to record Twitter space Ducky saved it And then I Posted it under there and said If you want to listen,
here it is Wait, where?
Oh, on the On the Twitter space Actually, I am Oh, she admits it She's not actually stalking you guys No, I I asked for his bail and we needed to pay For his release That's what jail is That's what That's what jail is See I commit to the bit I even have a jail system I have a judicial system It was 50 superchats That's messed up It was 50 superchats of anything they want Do you not know Have you never used a goal system?
Oh wait, I just did Go to your Oh, I have used the goal What should our goal be?
Oh no, I don't want them to decide What should our goal be?
When I first got this, I wrote nothing Oh wait, it's not working Nevermind, it's broken Yeah, it's broken guys, we can't use it Oh, a stream account Right I clicked ideas What idea should we do for the goal?
And it's like, I'll stream again on Friday When is like, an extra hour of the stream I'll do a stream where we explore more indie games Yeah, see, this is why This is why I'm not having them choose it Yeah Yeah, no This is why we can't Oh yeah, also like I loved when Mint ended the stream And then people were like,
noooo And there's one guy, and I was like, bye Minto Bye Minto Whoever you are, you're so sweet They're just like, well, if she wants the stream to be ended, that's fine
Please never leave again, especially on November What does that mean?
What does that mean?
Actually, yeah Actually, what does that mean?
I don't know, is it supposed to be NNN related?
Non-stop nut November Is that why you need me here?
Oh no, oh no Don't say it like that I don't think so I don't think that's what they meant I remembered when the organizer was like, hold on Can I ban Orca?
Yeah, sure
For 24 hours We'll do 10 minutes for you Orca I know you'll probably go crazy
I remember when the organizer was like The concert organizer was like Are you sure you don't want to do more postcards?
And then Mint was like, I can do more And I was like No More VIP, more people with VIP We can barely get through Oh, we still have a lot We still have this pile No, no, that's done No, we still have it I mean, I know our limits Hold on, that's not that bad I'm almost done with this pile If you guys see the pile and Mint's response to it Oh,
this is not too bad We still have to number them I know, it'll take two seconds to do that I'm not worried My signature is fast It's cause you have experience Keep signing Keep signing And I'll tell you when I see funny stuff in the chat If we keep signing,
then like We're not doing content We're signing guys, we're signing We're signing Guys, you're gonna love our setlist You're gonna love it Mint hates my setlist I don't hate it You hate it I hate everything She hated my setlist guys I was sad It's you What?
It's you What's that supposed to mean?
Is it Disney?
I wish I wish it were Disney It's not Disney, that's why she hates my setlist
Guys, just so you guys know, I'm not doing Soldier Boy No, no, no She wishes I was doing Soldier Boy LMAO Doki, I know my limits Bird and Mint hasn't learned her postcard lesson yet Yeah, oh my god, okay She was like, I can do it And then like yesterday,
she was telling me How she fucked up her hand yesterday Because of all of the postcards She has signed I'm just saying, I'm trying to Okay, sorry that I love my fans And I'm trying to have more of them Experience and get good stuff If you love your fans,
you should know your limits So you don't Fuck up your hands for the future Because then that means you won't be able to sign more In the future So you don't love your fans Because you're making sure your hands She's disassociating by the way She literally tuned me out In the middle of this conversation I literally looked at her And I could see the blankness in her eyes While I'm talking She literally stopped paying attention Keep signing
We haven't really done much here though We've just been dance practicing We had good food Our food And our food is Paid for it So I've been like I'm gonna be thinking about those green beans all day I was like, during our dance practice I was like, can I get boba tea And they were like,
yeah Yeah And I don't have to pay for it Which was really nice I got like a strawberry bubble tea, it was pretty good And I got like I got like popping bobas I, okay Have you guys ever had popping boba and coffee I had popping boba and coffee It was good,
because like It was sweet, and then the coffee was a little bitter So it counterbalanced it But it's like a, I don't Do you like fruity coffee?
I never had fruity coffee That was like the first time And you liked it?
Yeah, I liked it, because my coffee was bitter So it balanced it out But what flavor popping boba did you get?
I got lychee Yeah, it was really good I don't know, I've never I've never had it It was really good, I actually really liked it Anyway Is some of the Faze coffee fruity?
Because Sakana sent me every single one Oh really?
Yeah, and I haven't tried them yet It's like, I have coffee for like years now Because he sent me all of them That's a lot of coffee Oh my god, how did you get this pile?
What?
I'm signing There's so much What do you mean there's so much?
You might as well just start numbering I will, once I'm done, I'll start numbering them Okay, I'll put this here then I don't know what number we ended off Yeah, I think we ended on 10 But it's fine I gotta get through this too No, you might as well number Just to rest a little bit Okay,
okay Signing is more important than numbering Oh, you hear that?
She doesn't want to number them It made them special You can number too I'm still signing my end I know, I'm saying, I can only do my signature We both can number Oh my god, are you stupid?
That's why I'm cuter That's why I'm cuter Cuter?
You know what they say Girls are more cute when they're dumb I'm dumb Guys, am I cute?
Who's cuter, guys?
This is the dumbest This is actually the dumbest ever Who's cuter, guys?
It's not fair, it's on your stream It's on your channel Yeah, but it's still on your channel Probability wise Okay, make a poll Hold on, I know how to rig this Wait I'm literally here watching you making a poll Watch this Okay Wait
Alright, choose
Minky Minky No, it's Minky Minky It sounds like fucking monkey But you typed the wrong word Minky Minky might as well just be a fucking monkey Minky Wait, I said especially in November because of what's happening on Twitter with Femnani You guys just hate me You guys just hate me You found someone else God Who's that person again?
Maybe I should follow them Oh, go for it Yeah, go for it Minky Also, like, guys Minky I hope I'm not sick No You said it's the air It is the air If I'm sick, it's really Doki's fault It really is The air is, like, super dry I'm coughing even more But,
like My throat feels weird Really?
Yeah, but I think it's also because of the No, I think it's because of the dry air Making me cough so much That my throat feels, like, extra sensitive You gotta get that throat stuff For real What throat stuff?
The Paypaco stuff Oh, no, I do have it though I have it, but I didn't bring it Because, like, I was getting better But I just didn't think the air would be this dry Yeah Yeah It's dry Cause Minky Minky Minky This is her brain right now After signing all of these We don't have a humidifier in the hotel room Okay We just suffer The Minky Oh my god,
those guys are so funny Yeah, they are.
They're Canadian too Oh, wow They're so self-aware I've seen, like I follow them on TikTok And I've seen multiple people In comments on their videos Being like, growing up is realizing These guys have always been so funny Yeah, they're also wrestlers Did you know that?
Yeah, I know, they used to be wrestlers Before they went full-on content creation But they're so self-aware They literally do the dumbest things Yeah, I love their stuff so much There's one where they film themselves Filming themselves Yeah, yeah Every day I do this They jump and it's really cute And I do it every day I see my cat and I do it The Minky The Minky Minky Minky Minky is my brain right Minky,
Minky, Minky
We're signing We're signing We're signing so hard right now Are you guys proud of us?
Are you proud of us?
Guys
Guys, do you like me again?
Now that I'm back and you don't like Fem90 anymore, please Please Gee, my dragons wouldn't ditch me Do you have a clipper that they would like?
Nope So fast Because I would never give them the chance
Nope This is why I'm never coming back I'm leaving home and I'm never coming back
I told you they're more loyal to me
Why are my wisps loyal?
What do I need to do to make you guys more loyal?
I don't know, start your stream on time I do!
Oh, I didn't today You were like, I'm gonna make I was like, hey Min, we should start a stream And you were like, it's fine, we'll just wait a little longer I was waiting for the YouTube to connect
Oh my god How do I make you guys more loyal?
So proud Thanks, Crosis Medi over Doki Who's Medi?
Nobody
And that's how you shut it down That's how you shut it down Who's Medi?
What the hell?
Look Medi, I'm trying to prove a point here No, okay guys, you know what you have to do Time to make femme Medi There you go Just cause you're suffering doesn't mean you have to bring me down to your level Misery loves company, okay That is the saying That's just a toxic That is the saying That's just a toxic relationship It's not my relationship,
it's you and your dragoons Medi, just so you know, I'm just trying to prove a point Medi, Medi, Medi It's nothing personal I'm just trying to teach men how How to handle Handle these types of situations I'm gonna blow my nose Do it next to the Next to the Next to the mic Guys,
you better do it Or else Someone said Medi is handsome IRL I don't know Your dragoons meet, they're friends Oh my god It wasn't next to the mic It was so loud though It wasn't next to the mic Oh I'm sorry, I'm congested right now Stop being sick, get out of my room Okay,
you sign all the postcards You can sign the rest When you meet up next Oh my god What?
What did you say?
They're saying it was so loud
It's cause your fucking mic turned it up so high Meet up next, yes for the concert Yes for the concert, what the fuck do you mean?
We're gonna have like a pre And post concert stream, right?
Yeah Oh we're doing a pre concert stream?
I mean we should, should we?
No I think we should save ourselves for the concert Oh that's true And then we'll do one after the concert Yeah we'll do it after the concert There's a concert?
Can you read?
Look at the sign behind us Okay maybe you should like pin the website Okay And so like you know the poll And like I don't know what else you pinned there Oh Minky What did you pin?
I said hopefully the internet's good Okay hold on Guys please come to the concert We practiced really Everyone's really, I think everyone's really into Medi They're like, they're like he's so handsome Why are you telling me this?
Because That Nami thing is your problem You don't have to like I'm just saying everyone keeps bringing it up You don't have to like you know Drag others down to your level Medi is drop dead handsome I think they're obsessed with him for real Oh my god Oh my god Alright I'm just gonna say every wisp that I've met Is handsome or beautiful Or both How many marriage proposals did you get?
In like In like conventions Like two Oh that's alright What about you?
No then you'll feel bad
She has like her hands on her head right now Nobody loves me
She has her hands on her head Now she's sad I've done my job I
Remember I once complained about it because um I heard other people had gotten a lot of marriage proposal.
I was like, oh, I didn't get any.
Oh And then I had like two people come and are just like I'm coming to marriage proposals to you.
That's our pity
I Get when you say I hate them all the time Okay, I thought pity proposal Oh, I was like, what was I gonna do a phantom?
Oh, yeah the website.
Yeah, wait, it's just that's funny Your misery is funny to me
Oh Yeah,
this is the real toxic relationship everybody
Oh My god, it's alright, you know, nobody's perfect
I'm gonna go get my chapstick.
Oh, I'm gonna get her chapstick guys
While she gets her chapstick, I'm just gonna sign more stuff say what?
Signing oh somebody was like, oh, why aren't you signing more postcards?
Oh, why are you so slow?
Oh the one time I want to lock in and like Sign do my job.
You're like, no, don't do your job anymore.
I Can't multitask
They should be entertaining me.
Oh, okay entertain us entertain us entertain Exactly entertain me now, but she is a car mech
Done I'm done.
I want to be entertained entertain us now Minkees Minkees little minkees come on ever since mint bullet shamed me I can't I feel bad for people.
Do you want to explain for anybody who didn't see this?
So like my autograph my signature has a bullet, you know Cuz it's like bounty hunter and then she thinks it looks like somebody or something else And now and then she's shamed by bullet and said it's small Nice and now I She's bullet shamed me.
It looks probably better with a thinner
I I'm sorry.
I can't change it
There's no enhancers here It's not a size it's how you use it a bullet still kills no matter the size exactly Anyway, she's still bullet shamed me And now I'm sorry dragons when you see this signature I'm trying my best They'll all have really lovely memories about it.
We'll be like, haha It's small
Looked at me when she said
I Lost the cap in my pants.
Oh my god.
Why is my pile like this?
How do you sign this fast?
It's okay.
I had to be ahead.
Okay, but first of all Matara is even faster than I am.
Okay, wait What's Matara signature?
Uh, it's just her is she just signs her name But like I had to come up with a signature that is fast to sign with so Oh My gosh, you're gonna oh, you can make it look really detailed when we sign the standees true, we're gonna sign the sandies at the Theater at the at the theater.
Yeah.
Yeah
Just make it look good then and then nobody Like what does that imply?
Guys, it looks really nice
Or should we sing it wait Kami do you want us to wait until we're doing yeah the post-concert Concert you want it right now cuz it's kind of far.
It's like a whole month.
We'll be together again Yeah at the post-concert the post-concert.
I mean and at the concert so like I'll do anything for you.
Kami.
I love you.
Wait a minute.
Come here.
You my chat Kami's art.
She's so good.
Wait
Wait, oh That call me yeah.
Oh, it's this calm.
Yeah She's so good where's fan out of me
Oh You get everything I get nothing You're giving something.
You're not even having anything.
Let me have my artist.
Let me be the main character for two seconds.
What does she want?
Does she want it now or post-concert?
What do you want me to do?
Happy birthday to you.
Now you guys can pretend it's your birthday so we can get us to sing songs for you.
No, be serious.
It's a serious thing to stop what you're doing in a stream to sing happy birthday.
It's very rare to have both of us to sing for you at the same time.
It is a rare opportunity.
It's a rare opportunity.
You're like, wow, I can't believe it's also my birthday today.
Oh yeah, I was born just now.
Thank you, Yippie.
Thanks for all the gifted memberships and superchats.
Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you, guys.
I'm working for free.
What?
Yeah?
You have to stream Rust.
Today?
Are you going to?
I should.
That's why this one will be not so long.
Yeah, I should stream Rust.
I don't even know if my laptop can handle it.
We'll find out.
What I can do is...
Well, actually, I just have this pile.
I can...
After this, I can continue signing and then I'll just give it to you.
No, I can keep going.
I'll just stream Rust at a later time.
Okay, you guys are never getting that gun.
No, they are.
It's like a duo gun with Saekunos.
They can just have Saekunos stream it.
Okay.
Obviously, they want to get it from my stream.
Guys, plan B...
They want it from your stream.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
Plan B is Saekunos stream.
First, we're not at plan B yet.
We don't need to do plan B yet because there might be a hope for us to get it today.
When does it end?
I think it ends on the 17th.
So, there's plenty of time.
There's time.
Okay.
I don't know what's going on with my tribe now.
Apparently, I got a message from the leader and they were like, oh yeah, we had a concert yesterday.
A concert?
Yeah, in Rust.
They can do that?
Yeah, I was like, what?
A concert?
And obviously, I missed out on the concert because of my own concert.
And then two days later, he was like, we're parachuting today to the kingdoms.
Oh my god.
We're parachuting down to the kingdoms today.
And then I didn't reply.
What kind of game is Rust?
I don't know.
I don't even know.
There's like a lot.
You cannot build a nightclub in Rust.
Is it like GTA?
You can.
There's roleplayers there.
And there's like a cult.
There's like several cults.
Yeah, there's like a blood god cult.
And then there's like some musician in the cult.
And he does like...
Oh my god.
Wait, I'll show you a video.
Wait, we have to sing another happy birthday.
This is for Jonathan.
Okay, wait.
Is it really your birthday or because you pretend it's your birthday because I said that?
Today, three months ago, is my birthday.
Come on.
I told you.
At least they're honest.
Yeah.
That's why I was like, are you sure?
Are you absolutely sure?
I'll show you a clip.
Okay.
It was pretty cool.
Like, he literally comes up with these songs live.
Happy birthday to you.
Let's just do a happy birthday for everybody.
Okay, this is for everybody.
It's all your birthdays now.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Metal Gear Solid 2.
Everyone.
Happy birthday to you.
All right, you guys are going to listen to this too because I'm just going to play it on my phone.
Okay.
This is like...
It might not be loud enough.
The noise gate might grab it.
Okay, wait.
How's the internet, though?
I'm trying to...
Thanks for clipping my stuff, guys, so I can just pull it up on...
Oh, my God.
Which apple juice is mine?
I didn't drink any.
I didn't either, but one's from last night.
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I think...
Do you remember drinking a lot of apple juice?
No.
Me neither, though.
Oh, I see you.
What is this?
Oh, this is...
Okay, so he makes up these songs.
So he basically live sings all of this.
Oh, okay.
What is going on?
He's dropping the beat for us.
Okay.
What?
The blood god.
Okay, I'm just gonna drink this one, then, because it has more apple juice.
That's like...
Yeah, this guy fucking goes around creating music.
It's crazy.
That's like...
It's just everything.
Like, you can gamble, too.
There's a casino in Rust.
Okay.
Love for the blood god, love for the blood god.
Praise be to the blood god.
Praise be.
Alright.
Keep signing.
I'm signing.
Praise be to the blood god.
I think you'd like the blood god.
That's a Warhammer.
Yeah, I think you'd like joining the blood god cult.
Oh, probably.
Yeah, I think you'd actually be their number one lieutenant.
I am the blood god.
You are the blood god.
I'm ascended into blood goddom.
You're reincarnated into it.
Yeah.
I wanna be the blood god.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry we're not playing video games from behind.
Yeah, sorry guys.
We're really behind.
If we had gotten these the first night, I think we would have been able to play the game.
I think so, too.
I really wanted us to play the Mario Party because I wanted us to be two and then two NPCs.
Because the computers are ruthless.
Oh, yeah.
I know.
I remember.
Yeah.
We can just play normal.
Let's make a collab with some people.
I wanna play with Doobie.
Oh, yeah.
You wanted to do...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I wanna play with Doobie.
Yeah, she was talking about it with me.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Well, not that.
I said she as in you.
Oh, yeah.
I was like...
Well, I brought it up to her.
I was just like, do you want to play the Mario Party?
So, maybe.
We'll see.
We'll see whenever Doobie is adjusted to streaming again.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Dokopon would take forever.
Dokopon would not...
What's Dokopon?
It's Mario Party, but if you actually want to lose friendships.
Okay, that just doesn't explain anything.
It's like more cruel Mario Party.
Like how?
Like, it is more cruel in what it takes away from you.
You know how it's just like, I took a star.
Like, no.
Dokopon will take away your life.
Like, it's just...
Like, how?
But it's also really long.
Like, sometimes it takes like a week.
We would have to like...
Wait, what?
I think the Sloppy Sisters would be good with it.
Oh, true.
Yeah.
Yeah, Dokopon is just flat out evil.
It's just really...
Why are we the Sloppy Sisters?
Why couldn't you be the Slop Squad?
It was like, earlier, Doki was like, I hate that name.
I hate the Sloppy...
I call us the Slop Squad.
And my chat's like, you mean the Sloppy Sisters?
Can't we be normal?
We're VTubers, we're not normal.
We're already not normal, we're VTubers.
I just wanna be close.
I love being a Sloppy Sister.
I'm a Sloppy Sister.
I'm gonna make us a theme song.
Or do it.
We're gonna Slop, Slop, Slop.
The Sloppy Sisters.
Slop, Slop, Slop.
Stop ignoring me.
I want you to think about what you say.
What does that mean?
I want you to process your thoughts there.
You know when someone gives you bad food, it's Slop.
So we're bad people?
No, we're just like a Sloppy Joe, you know.
Why is it even called that?
Sloppy means messy.
We're messy cows.
The meat isn't even like a patty, it's literally just grounded meat.
We're just messy girls.
Have you never had a Sloppy Joe's?
No, I have, but I didn't know why.
Then you would know that it's not actually a patty, it's just grounded beef.
No, there is a patty.
No, it's not.
Yeah, it's a sandwich.
No, a Sloppy Joe is like a ground beef, instead of shaped into a patty.
It's not ground beef.
It's just like it's not shaped into a patty, it's literally just...
I think I'm thinking of barbecue.
You're not thinking of barbecue?
I think I'm thinking of like a barbecue sandwich.
Maybe I've never had a Sloppy Joe before.
I love being Sloppy's sister, but you don't even know it's like the...
No, Sloppy!
Okay, Sloppy is not just Sloppy Joe.
Sloppy also means messy.
It's a slang.
So we're the messy sisters.
Yeah, we're the messy sisters.
But like, what do you mean by that?
We're just messy.
Yeah, but what do you mean by that?
I mean, did you see our restaurant?
It was not clean.
Oh, true.
We're the messy gals.
Right, guys?
Don't encourage this.
I'm a mess.
My life, my afterlife is a mess.
Oh, I know.
You died because your Oshi graduated.
What?
What do you mean what?
That's literally your lore!
What are you talking about?
I actually don't even know how I died.
I just spawned in like a forest.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
You didn't even rewind your stream?
Is that it?
What do you mean?
What are you actually talking about?
Oh, she doesn't... Guys, now we know she doesn't even watch back her streams, guys.
I don't even know what the hell you're talking about.
Oh, yeah, you don't...
You don't watch your own streams?
Yeah, of course.
Just because I need to double check stuff.
I like getting embarrassed.
Why?
Why do you get embarrassed?
I watch back my own streams, especially because I know I'm funny.
You don't make yourself laugh?
No!
What?
I don't know why they think I'm funny.
Do you guys think I'm funny?
Okay, now you're just like trying to get your ego stroked.
Maybe because I'm in front of you.
Yes.
Do you think frog bird's funny?
Frog bird.
Where's croaky?
It's just me.
Hello, I'm croaky.
Hey, guys, it's croaky.
Oh, yeah, I showed Mint my nendoroid.
Oh, yeah.
I showed it to her.
We got updates of it.
I saw it.
Don't know leaks on the parts.
You kind of just leaked.
No, I said no leaks on the parts.
I don't know what parts are in it.
Yeah.
Sure.
I won't say anything.
Don't leak your own parts, though.
I won't.
I'm almost done with my pile.
No, you're not.
Look at this pile.
That is done.
You have to do numbers.
Oh, I know, but this is actual signature.
What the fuck?
Thank God.
I'm almost done with my pile.
I wish we could show the pile, but then we'd be doxing the postcard.
Yeah, we can't show how many postcards there are.
Because it would reveal the art.
Or what the postcards are.
Yeah, the art of the postcards.
The art's really cute, though.
It's really cute.
We have outfits for it.
Yeah.
It's cute.
We're idols.
Yeah.
In the outfits.
In the postcard.
I don't know about that.
Now you're revealing more and more about the postcard.
You said we have outfits, though.
We have outfits.
It could have been any outfit.
But...
Yeah.
I don't think we're idols on that stage.
What do you mean?
Okay, when you saw that one song...
That one song...
That was really good.
I was thinking my dance lessons definitely paid off there.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Leaking.
No, we're not leaking anything.
We're hinting so that you can be like...
You get curious.
You're like, what could they be talking about?
I must go to the concert.
In Atlanta, Georgia.
On December 14th.
Yeah.
At the Tabernacle Atlanta, Georgia.
Also, if you can't make it, do not worry.
We're planning on uploading, like, clips of our favorite performances.
Yeah.
Yeah, so don't worry.
So there will be clips.
But try and make it if you can.
Yeah, yeah.
Because it's not going to be the full concert.
Yeah, try and make it if you can.
Yeah, so, like, we would really appreciate it.
Because if you guys come to the concert, it'll give us more opportunities in the future to have some more similar stuff.
More similar stuff.
So if you guys want more concerts from us, like, you know, it really means a lot if you guys come to the concert.
Or Mint's going to cry.
I will.
She will cry on stage.
Actually, I think they'll enjoy it.
No.
They'll enjoy it.
Actually, they might enjoy it.
Okay, if you guys come to the concert, or she won't cry on stage.
No!
That's right.
She'll withhold her tears.
Unless you come to the concert.
There will be a full fan recording as well.
We figured it out today.
Oh, shit.
I'll cry.
Well, still come if you can.
Still come, because it won't be... it's not the same.
No, that...
Like...
I know, we're like in between being like, you know, don't...
It's fine, but also like...
It'll make us really happy, and then we'll have more opportunities in the future.
And then maybe those opportunities will let us have streaming tickets in the future, you know, guys?
Like, it gives us a chance to have streaming tickets in our next concert, if we ever do a next one.
Like I say, in our next concert, as if we're definitely going to do a next one, but we don't even know.
We don't even know.
Like, we only have this one.
So, if it goes well, that means like, you know, we're worth investing in for concerts, guys.
Yeah, exactly.
They'll be like, oh, we gotta bring these girls back.
Yeah, we gotta bring these girls back to do more concerts.
With maybe more guests, maybe other 3D guests.
Also, we're all just like, like saying like, hypothetically, we do... there's no plans.
Yeah.
Like...
We're just... we're dreaming big, you guys.
We're dreaming big.
Some deep concert goes well!
This is like the hardest we've ever shilled anything, I think.
I know, I know.
That's like the hardest we've ever...
People don't listen to us.
We're like literally...
We're actually fake.
This is so sad.
Because we want to have more... like more... like, have a chance to have like streaming tickets next time.
Yeah.
So like, we want to do another concert in the future so we can actually provide streaming tickets for those who can't make it.
Because we worked really hard on this one.
This person said, get Doobie for the next concert.
We have Doobie for this concert!
We have Doobie for this one!
Like, what?!
That's so funny.
Oh my god, Doobie was like...
I wanna do the worm.
Oh, hell yeah.
I wanna see Doobie do the worm.
I wanna see Doobie do the worm too.
Doobie do the worm.
We don't know what she's gonna do.
No.
It was just us two at the rehearsals.
Yeah.
So, Doobie's gonna doob.
Whatever she doobing was.
And she's gonna doob what she wants to doob.
Yeah.
She's gonna doob it.
I love her name.
I know, it's so fun to say.
I'm doobing it.
Is this mine?
I don't...
I don't know.
I'm gonna drink it.
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm not the sickie here.
Guys, if Min gets sick, I'm sorry.
I don't know if I'm sick, that's the thing.
I don't think you are.
I'm just coughing a little bit.
Yeah, but you were blowing your nose too.
No, every time I stream, I blow my nose.
Because, like, every stream I blow my nose because I talk so much that, like, the saliva...
Not saliva, my nose gets congested.
Oh.
It's like a medical thing.
And I...
I actually...
It's not serious, but...
I have such a consistent runny nose, I actually think it's brain fluid.
No wonder.
Which is, like, apparently an actual reason...
Sometimes the reason that your nose is running is that you...
Wait, really?
Yeah, I looked it up because I was like...
What?
I was like, why is my nose actually always so runny?
Wait, what?
How is brain fluid...
It's, like, leaking through.
No, you're fucking with me, there's no way.
No, I'm dead serious.
Because I have that...
Oh, no, is that why I'm getting more stupid?
That's why we're dumb.
Wait, no, don't say that, guys.
Okay, wait, let's chat thing.
Google doctor.
I googled it.
No, there was, like, some specific stuff about it, but I was just like...
There's no way, no one will say that.
And I was like, um...
No, I actually should go to a doctor about this because I...
I was like, this is getting weird.
So, I...
I've had this for, like, years, but it's only when I stream.
No, my nose never stops running, actually.
But it's only also in one nostril.
Oh, okay.
So, I think it's, like, dripping through that nostril from my brain.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's not good.
It's like when you try to Google what's wrong with you and you get cancer.
I know.
Literally losing brain cells as you stream.
I mean, it explains everything.
Yeah.
I used to be really smart.
If I go to heaven, I'll use this as my testimony on why I went to heaven.
Oh, because you're stupid?
No, brain fluid.
I think my marker's starting to die.
We have more, but, like, it's thinner.
I think it's this one.
This is the bad one.
Yeah, it's the thin... No, that's the gold one.
That's gold.
Oh, you're right.
This is a really thin one.
Oh, let me try.
Can you hand me the test one?
Yeah.
Thank you.
We should auction that off.
Oh, no, because this one was dry.
Oh, yeah.
Well, hold on.
Oh, no.
It's pretty dry.
Just kidding.
Yeah, the others are gold.
Don't you taste it for us and see if it's brain fluid.
God, your chat is so damn bad.
Uh...
I don't know why.
What do you mean you don't know why?
Yes, you do.
Why?
What's that?
Oh, let me look at your Twitter replies.
What's my Twitter replies?
Let me look at your Twitter replies.
Okay, I don't know why I tried with this one again.
It's so thin, and it's so weak.
Maybe we can ask them to give us more markers.
But we literally just asked them for these ones.
Yeah, but what time is it?
We're down bad for you, Doki.
Oh, my God.
No, I know why.
Get a room.
Get out of my chat if you're going to just propose to Doki over and over again.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
Maybe one day.
Maybe one day they'll start proposing to you.
Actually, this one got better the more I used it.
Uh-oh.
Maybe I should have been using this one from the start.
And I'm almost done even.
You know, you still have to number them.
I know, but that's with silver.
I gave you the silver, right?
You're not going to help me number them?
No.
But your handwriting is nicer than mine.
No, it's not.
You know that.
It is actually.
No, it's not.
My handwriting fucking sucks.
Please marry me, AI Minto.
Oh, yeah, the AI.
What does AI Mint say?
Oh, you have to have an account, and I don't have one.
Oh my god, this one is so much nicer than the one I've been using.
Wait, really?
Yes.
Oh, did you have to like...
Lift up the pile to a random one?
What's wrong with this one?
It's just thick.
It's like more shiny, see?
Oh, wait, it is.
Yeah.
Want to trade?
No, I'm almost done.
I'm sorry, guys.
Guys, it's gotcha.
It's literally gotcha.
I don't know if mine...
This one was so bad at first, though.
Yeah, but then it got really good.
But then you gave love to it.
This is what happens when you, you know, start loving...
I love it and nurture it.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm...
I know you don't know what that feels like.
I'm turning over a new leaf, guys.
I'll be nice to you now.
That's a cap.
What the...
Come here, fan art of you.
Wait, I want to see it.
Come here.
Look!
Sorry, Doki.
I'm just hiding.
Why are we...
Why is it eggs?
Wait, why is it eggs?
What is...
Wait a minute.
Why is it eggs?
What does that mean?
Oh, look at this, too.
Oh!
Wait, I like how I caught...
Then he's like...
You bullied Kame.
That's so mean.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, you better be.
Thanks for the art.
She's my baby.
Guys!
Peer pressure works!
Okay.
Time to number.
That's when you know.
I'm going to try out your marker.
Peer pressure works, guys.
No, no, no.
It's this one.
This one?
Okay.
I think so.
That just, like, proves my point.
Yeah.
This one sucks.
This one's bad.
Okay!
Time to number.
Where's the old one?
I put the silver...
I gave the silver to you.
No, I mean, like, the ones that...
What?
No, I gave you the old silver.
No, no, no.
I'm not talking about...
I'm talking about...
Oh, wait.
No, it's in there.
No, it's in here.
It's here.
No, I'm saying these.
Oh!
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I gave them to you.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This is...
Alright.
I have a lot more to go on my own.
Seven, six, five, four, three, two, one.
Okay.
Alright, we're on number eleven.
Baby!
I'll give this to you since I finished them.
What?
These.
These are all the finished ones.
Oh, my goodness.
These.
I need to go blow my nose.
Come over to the mic.
No.
See, guys.
She doesn't love you.
Fine, I'll do it to the mic.
You know what that means.
Here we go, guys.
I'm going to blow my nose.
That's it.
That's so weak.
It's the brain fluid.
How are they going to Toskaroo that?
Brain fluid?
I sneezed.
I gave them a real show, okay?
That's not what the wimpy blow right there.
No, a sneeze is the real show.
See, they're still saying Toskaroo.
One big boom.
Boom!
Oh, my God.
We brought it back.
Wait.
Okay.
I need more space.
Boom.
Certified boom.
Well, guys, know that I am numbering every single one of these with love.
Okay?
Because now I love you guys.
Whoa.
Since otherwise, if I don't love you guys, you will find someone else.
Guys, I'm here.
You guys will create creatures.
You guys will create horrible things.
That's someone else right here, guys.
No, they don't need you anymore.
They don't need you anymore.
My channel is YouTube at Doki Bird.
Use Gamersups code Boomer.
Oh, hey.
This is what...
Hey.
What?
Ow!
Oh, my God.
Why did you punch me?
You know why.
Wait, what did it say?
Oh, my God.
You know why.
Why did you punch me?
This is actually abusive relationship.
I bet like...
They're watching right now.
I'm gonna kill that guy.
Fucking Kana Udo requested that Doki punch me in the shoulder.
I'm literally going to kill you.
I will...
I will send you to hell.
Okay, let me reply to this.
This is...
I just get abused every day, everybody.
This is why I'm so angry all the time.
Actually, can you like hit my back one more time?
Because not as hard as you did.
But like not as hard as you did.
Ow!
I said not as hard.
Oh, sorry.
That wasn't as hard.
That feels good.
Every punch is a punch for you, Wisp.
Jesus Christ, I'm like your chiropractor.
I told you, I'm sore.
She's so stressed out.
That felt good.
Are you a...
Are you an M?
I think I'm a switch.
You're a switch?
Alright.
Sometimes it's fun to be the one inflicting the pain.
Maybe.
What's your chat?
Are they M or S?
What are you guys?
I think there's various because sometimes I say things and they're like, yo, mint, I'm not into that.
Yo, hold.
Hold.
They're literally timing me out.
They're like, yo, man.
Bro, I only see you as a bro, dude.
That's fine.
We're all bros here.
I thought this was supposed to be my bro-tuber.
What happened?
Yeah, we're the bros.
Hey, have him message me instead because you need to sign.
What?
You don't even have him.
Oh, I don't?
Yeah, because I was like, do you have him?
And you were like, no.
No, you asked me about someone else.
No, I asked you about...
Oh, it's TikTok.
I had TikTok up, sorry.
We're talking about Kanaru because we want to ask Kanaru about something regarding 3D stuff.
No, but you asked for someone else.
No, no, in the past when we first asked him to do something else.
Remember?
And I was like, do you have him?
He was like, no.
Oh, I don't have Discord now, I don't think.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
You're like, y'all haven't messaged me.
And I was like, you don't even have him.
Yeah, good.
Yeah, that's why you get hit.
Oh, sorry, I went back to TikTok.
She's so brain-rotted from TikTok.
It's a TikTok about Disney.
Yeah.
You're so brain-rotted.
That's literally brain-rot.
Maybe.
Hold on, let me show you.
Okay, I'll show you some funny TikToks.
Look at this one.
What's this?
Guys, this is not a reaction.
But you can't see the video.
She's literally making me react right now.
She's literally trying to make me react.
But with no video.
You don't need a video.
The creature.
I think there was a video for this.
Yes, the creature was a cow.
Reaction over.
Sorry, I think it's scary.
Look at this.
But sometimes I get really good ideas from TikTok.
I want to do this.
Look at this.
So, it's a postcard.
Wouldn't that make really cool merch?
Wait, how do they do that?
I know!
How do they do that?
Isn't that crazy?
That's crazy.
You guys, I get good ideas from TikTok, okay?
Guys, we're reacting.
Don't say what it is though.
No, they don't.
Oh, it does say where it's from though.
Yeah, you can literally get that manufacturer.
Because they credit it.
Yeah, I know.
It's really down bad merch.
Yeah, but it would be cool.
There's something there that can be used, you know?
But when would you ever put it there?
What's the context?
I don't know.
It's a novelty item.
That's true.
You're just feeling a little wild that day.
It's just every day.
Every day I'm feeling wild.
What am I on?
029.
We're doing our best here.
I signed all my postcards.
I'm trying my best here.
Wait, there's this too?
Yes.
Oh my god, it got bigger in this pile.
Yeah, because I signed postcards.
Oh my god.
I think once I sign this, or once I number these, it's gotta be it.
Yeah, there's a lot.
Doki is really behind you guys.
It's okay.
It's a giant pile.
Say some motivating things in the chat for Doki Bird signing.
Okay, then you have to read it out loud because I'm not looking at it right now.
I'm fucking trying to sign here.
She's trying to sign here.
Okay, if you're going to ask them to give me motivation words, you gotta read it.
You can win.
You feel great.
You can do it, Doki.
We believe in her.
Think about Apex.
Love Doki.
Doki can do this.
Keep it up, Doki.
You got this.
Doki, you're smarter than me.
Wait a second.
Go, Doki Bird.
I definitely feel motivated after that person.
You will make it.
Okay, I'm not dying, guys.
I'm not dying.
I feel like you're like, oh my god, she's gonna die.
This Sharpie is not great.
I need another silver Sharpie, please.
Wait, what color was that?
That was exactly the silver.
That's funny.
Guys, I hope you guys like my set list.
Because Mint doesn't.
Thoughts and prayers for Doki.
Mint doesn't like my set list.
Okay, keep signing and don't care about your set list right now.
What do you mean?
She criticized my set list.
She criticized my set list and then like, made me sad.
Oh my god.
You criticized my intelligence and made me sad.
Okay, like...
One is not the same.
Why would the truth make you sad?
Oh, there we go.
See, everybody?
This is what I have to deal with.
I thought you wanted to be cute.
Don't you want to be cute?
No.
Okay.
I just want my Oshis to be cute.
If they're cute, then it's nothing matters.
You're dead anyway, so like...
I'm ugly because my Oshis are cuter.
They had to steal the points of cuteness.
I'm my own Oshi.
Wait, this one's leaky.
It's really wet.
Oh my gosh, why did I get a damn decent pen around here?
They gave us so many, and I don't understand how they're all good.
I know, I'm struggling with all of them.
Yeah, they're all like semi-bad.
Like, I don't want it to leak onto the next one.
Okay, what about Garfield?
I am my own non-cat Oshi.
Oh guys, you know like Min was saying how she wanted to be...
What's his name?
She wanted to be that guy in Garfield.
That guy in the oven.
You're like, I want to be the guy in the oven.
I don't think that was on stream.
I know, I know.
But like, we were talking about...
But like, what's his name again?
Lyman.
She wants to be Lyman.
Yeah, I was just like, who can I be?
I'll be Lyman.
Is it Liam?
No, it's Lyman.
His name is Lyman?
Lyman.
The guy, he was locked in the basement.
She's talking about the Halloween Garfield game.
I never realized like, how to pronounce.
Also, she doesn't even know who Nermal is.
I was like, no, you should be Nermal.
And then she was like, who's Nermal?
I was like, Nermal's hot.
She's like, Nermal's, she's so hot.
I was like, she's a guy.
I don't know Garfield lore, you guys, okay?
Sue me, okay?
Guys, I told you guys, nobody's perfect.
Yeah, exactly.
She judged me for not knowing like, Metal Gear references, but she barely knows anything about Garfield.
Okay, but Metal Gear is like, very impactful.
Oh, and Garfield isn't?
You're a gamer.
How is Garfield not impactful?
Garfield is not gaming.
Garfield is like, life.
Garfield is literally everywhere.
So is Metal Gear.
Okay.
If you look.
At least Funko Pops has Garfield.
Oh, I'm not crying that Funko Pops has Garfield and not Metal Gear.
Yeah, if you go to a Hot Topic, you'd find Garfield stuff.
If I go to a Hot Topic, I wouldn't find Metal Gear.
I don't know, I think you might find Metal Gear now.
No, we gotta go to a Hot Topic.
That would require me going to a Hot Topic.
Garfield.
I'm not dissing Garfield.
Garfield has an amusement park.
Really?
Yeah.
Wait, no, it was the Garfield Dark Ride that people were having sex on.
Wait, what?
Yes.
Oh, you don't know about this Garfield sex ride?
Because, like, that's against the Garfield rules.
That's illegal.
Okay, so dark rides are just notorious for people having sex on them.
And for some reason, the Garfield one...
And why do you know this?
Because I watch a bunch of stuff about amusement parks.
Wait, was it from, what was it called?
Defunctland?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, that was from Defunctland?
Yeah.
Bro, what?
And they got stories from people being like, yeah, in my teens I went on the Garfield ride and got a little frisky with my girl.
Like, people were admitting to it.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's why they closed it down.
No.
They should have been arrested.
How dare they?
Zero?
Fifteen?
How dare they not pay attention to the Garfield lore and just do all that scandalous things.
Tarnish the reputation of Garfield.
Wait, so John doesn't fuck?
I don't think so.
Did you watch Lasagna Cat?
What?
Are you a real Garfield fan?
Lasagna Cat?
Wait, no, wait.
Oh, no.
Wait, I might know it.
I just didn't know the name of it.
It's like the live action, it's a YouTube channel.
Like, yeah, people are calling you a fake fan.
No, I know it.
It's like the one where... No, I know it.
I just didn't know the channel name.
It goes really trippy, right?
And then at one point it repeats John doing the same thing over and over again.
You know, I know.
See, I know my Garfield shit.
Yeah, but you didn't know the name.
I didn't know the name of it.
And you didn't know the name of it.
I didn't know the name.
I know it.
I just forgot the name of it.
I watched almost... Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
You don't even know Nermal.
60.
Sorry, whoever gets 60, I messed it up.
I never do that.
Well, then you can number it.
I give up.
I'm done.
Then you do mine.
No, I listened to almost the whole video of people calling in about how many partners they've been with.
Oh, yeah, that one.
I remember that one.
Yeah, that's my crowning achievement in my afterlife.
So you watch Lasagna Cat, but not, like, actually things from Jim Davis?
No, why would I...
No.
I don't think so, no.
But Lasagna Cat is basically reenacting... Yeah, Lasagna Cat is reenacting the strips.
Yeah, but it's not from the creator.
That's fine.
It's not from the creator.
It's a parody.
Yeah, why would anyone do that?
Yeah, see, see, see.
You know what's funny?
Like, Jim Davis literally was like, I created Garfield so I can make a lot of money.
Well,
I don't think Garfield is notorious for having an ass.
You don't know that.
You've never seen that before.
Is he?
Never seen it.
Yeah, Snake actually has cake.
Alright, let me see.
Gar... Oh no, I shouldn't Google that.
You're looking up Gar...
I know, I know, I shouldn't Google that.
Garfield ass.
No, I'm not.
I'm not looking up Garfield.
I'm getting, I'm getting deja vu.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not looking it up.
I'm getting...
I'm not, I realize that that was a mistake.
I'm getting deja vu all of a sudden.
I realize looking up Garfield ass is not, is not appropriate.
Look up naked Garfield and you'll get it.
Probably with his name Andrew Garfield.
Oh my god.
Guys, I realize that it could be a mistake if I try to look that up.
Deja vu real.
61 everybody.
I have more.
I don't know why my silver keeps running out.
I think it's the postcard paper.
I think so too.
I mean my, my, my marker for this is still working.
But look, look how the silver is reacting.
Maybe it's just the silver.
Maybe it's just me.
Maybe it's just you.
I'm too hot to handle and it's drying it out.
H -O -T-T-O-G-O.
You can't hang me hot to go.
That's not on the set list by the way.
I hope she means hot to go.
Yeah.
We were like, oh my god, wouldn't it be funny if like we started a concert.
See, look at this.
Oh yeah.
We started a concert and we're like, hey guys, let's welcome Sabrina Carpenter.
We start the concert off like that.
Oh, that's meat espresso.
Oh my god, and then look at this one.
It's so milky.
Look.
Oh yeah.
There's no in between.
Maybe just let it know like.
I'm actually suffering here guys.
Yeah, interchange it so then like the ink drops down.
Yeah, yeah.
Cause you're letting it dry.
You're doing it so fast that the ink can't catch up.
Maybe.
I think that's basically it.
I think the ink's not catching up to the rest of the postcards.
Yoki, there's a fan art of Femmedy now.
Alright, look it up.
You do it.
No.
I'm signing.
Do you want me to sign or not?
Okay, I'll look it up.
I like the SNL parody of that.
Here we go.
What the fuck is that?
It's Merian.
I don't know what their character is like.
It's a bird.
Oh, a bird.
It's literally a dragoon.
How the fuck?
You're supposed to be a dragoon.
Why are you...
Oh my god.
We're wiping each other's noses.
Why are you a person?
What do you mean I'm a...
No, I meant Femmedy.
Why are you a person?
You're supposed to be a dragoon.
I'm tired now.
You're not.
You're only at 60.
You can finish the rest.
No, I...
I can't finish my other ones.
I still have this left.
I haven't signed yet.
Guys, she's not working anymore.
She doesn't care.
I'm doomscrolling through Twitter.
I care, cause I'm still...
If you cared, you'd be done by now.
No, I'm just slow.
Because...
Okay, okay.
No, no, no.
I care more because I put more love into each of my autographs.
You're just like a machine.
You're like a manufacturing machine.
This is like talking to a child.
It's like a kindergarten teacher trying to fucking rationalize for this stupid child.
That their parents dropped one hour early because they didn't want to deal with her anymore.
This is your bullet.
This is a song.
It's stupid.
I think it is.
Brain fluid.
I think...
I think mine is just...
Mine is just like a medical issue, but it's definitely not brain fluid.
Hers actually is.
I'm letting it dry, by the way, because I'm letting the ink roll down, like you said.
Sure.
Zero, six, eight.
Some of them are...
Look, it's too wet.
It's too wet.
Then you let it dry too often.
Maybe you shouldn't wait it too long.
No, what are you talking about?
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm gonna go blow my nose.
Again, again.
You guys, are you ready for the funny number?
Zero, six, nine.
Oh, you should do something special on that one.
What?
Add a smiling face.
Okay.
I added a smiling face.
You should write one of them and be like, help me.
We already did that, didn't we?
No, we didn't do it.
Oh no, you did the sad face.
You should make one of them and write, help me.
And then somebody who has never watched the stream of the signing is gonna get that.
It's still too dry.
This sucks, man.
I can't work under these conditions.
I'm only on 70.
You see, I don't complain.
Okay, here, you can sign with this then.
Sign with that pen.
I can't because I have to do the regular stuff.
Okay, well then you can do the rest.
I'm gonna get to 100 and you do the rest of the numbers.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's a good idea.
That's not fair.
Why are you laughing?
My signature is harder.
Where was that number?
I literally...
That's not fair.
My signature is harder.
The way you screamed it like a literal child.
Who's the child now?
Oh, yeah, it's if I just did like...
That's not fair.
I don't wanna do half the work.
Oh, yeah, half the work.
You're still...
Yeah, half the work is writing half the numbers.
Yeah, your signature is literally shorter than mine.
That's not my fault.
It's not shorter because we literally both have the same number of letters in our names.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, you're writing the bird.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I put more love into my signatures.
It's just your name is longer.
That's not my fault.
You should have renamed yourself something better.
Somebody can't fucking count, apparently.
You're like, oh, your name is like the same length as mine.
I thought you were writing just doki.
No, because there's so many doki's in the fucking world.
Okay, well, I don't know.
I think someone would look at this and know that it's you.
I can't use this pen anymore.
Actually, I'm gonna lose my...
This was such a bad idea, numbering these, because the pens don't work.
This was your idea.
I'm actually getting so frustrated.
This was your idea regarding numbering.
Because I was like, just do one, two, three, four, five, six.
You're like, no, I'm gonna put zero.
That's not the problem.
I'm actually getting so annoyed by this, actually.
What the fuck?
She like threw her Sharpie at the wall.
Yeah.
She's having a temper tantrum right now, guys.
I'm actually really...
Count to ten and then you'll feel better.
I'm actually annoyed.
You should count to ten.
Don't talk to me, I'm angry.
Count to ten and then you'll feel better.
No.
I learned that in kindergarten.
It's gonna work on you.
But they look so ugly because they don't look good.
What do you mean?
They're drying.
No, it's not.
They're fine.
Look.
Use the other one.
It's too wet.
Shouldn't we have three silver?
We only have three.
Look at this.
Oh, wait, that's not the right one.
Hold on.
Wait, why don't you use this one?
Because it dries out.
It becomes the same like that.
Look, it's fine.
Guys, it's fine.
Just put it on this and let it dry.
Oh, my God.
Look, I sacrificed precious signing time to deal with a child.
I'm so annoyed.
I'm gonna end the stream.
You're just...
She's just acting, guys.
She's not gonna end.
It's so ugly.
It's hard because I have to wait for it to dry.
So it's taking longer.
Oh, no.
It's taking longer.
Who ordered the VIP packages?
Anybody in chat?
Are you guys excited?
Getting the ones where Mint doesn't cry about it.
I got it.
Good for you.
You might get one that has...
Look, it's literally gooping there.
It's gonna drip onto it.
It makes it extra special.
Guys, who wants a gooping one?
Does anyone want the goopy marker?
See, they want it.
They want the goopy one.
It's actually dripping out, you guys.
They're into it.
I didn't know that.
Why do we...
Oh, shit, I messed up again.
Why do we have three silvers and none of them work?
She's angry.
I'm actually angry.
I'm actually so annoyed.
Because she's angry.
What do I do?
I think she might hit me.
You're the one who actually hit me.
I don't want her to regret it.
Okay, I'll give you one hit.
It'll make you feel better.
Hint about what?
I'll give you one hit.
Oh, hits.
No, I don't want a hit.
I don't want a hit.
It'll make you feel better.
It'll help your aggression.
Maybe if I hit you.
I said I'd let you hit me once.
Oh, I thought you meant you were gonna hit me.
No, I said I'd let you hit me once.
No.
Okay.
And I'll never let that opportunity come to her again.
I'm just having to switch between three pens and they all shit.
They're all fucking shit.
I'm having a good time, guys.
I'm actually having a good time.
I'm actually gonna stop at 100, okay?
So you do the rest.
No.
Yes, because I actually am gonna lose my mind if I continue with these.
But it's content.
They like that.
No, I'm actually...
They want you to lose your mind.
No.
They like it when you get a little delulu.
Not like this.
Don't make me do more work.
I'll cry.
And 100.
Okay.
Doki will sign the rest after 100.
No.
What did you do?
Oh, hey, look at...
Oh, you should fill up the other circle.
Make it extra special.
Oh, my God.
But it's dripping.
Wait, is it actually...
It's actually dripping, yes.
I think this one is actually, like, faulty.
Look, it's, like, dripping all over the desk.
Wait, yeah, I think it's...
And it's dripping on the postcards.
Wait, what?
Yes.
Wait, I think you gotta stop using that one.
But that's the only one that works.
Bless you.
Thank you.
We should've asked for more markers.
Oh, my God.
That's why it's dripping on me.
Oh, it's dripping on my pants.
No.
My cinnamon roll pants.
That's bad.
I know.
Maybe they'll...
Maybe they'll pay for your pants.
These were a gift from my mom.
Oh, no.
Can you wash it?
It's Sharpie.
I'm pretty sure you can wash Sharpie.
There's, like, a solution for that, right?
I'm pretty sure.
Guys, how do you wash Sharpie, guys?
We need help.
Get soap.
Wait.
Alcohol wipes.
Alcohol wipes help.
Oh, yeah.
Alcohol wipes.
Oh, I think I have one, actually.
Yeah, that should work.
Because, like, Sharpie is removable by alcohol wipes.
Or rubbing alcohol.
Yeah.
That's usually it.
This is it.
Make it count.
Guys, does hand sanitizer work?
Chat fixes pants.
Don't use wipes.
No wipes.
Dab it.
Yes, yes, yes.
They said hand sanitizer should work.
Yeah.
Dab.
Don't rub.
You know how to dab?
Show me.
She dabbed in front of me, guys.
Did it work?
I think it... oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
This is... it's all over the desk.
How do you... you need to get, like, a tissue and then start dabbing it.
Yeah, I thought that one wasn't used.
She's getting tissue right now, guys.
God, now it does look like a dick.
Guys, I'm sorry.
My signature with my bullet doesn't look like a...
I'm sorry.
No.
No, the bullet doesn't look like a bullet.
I'm sorry to whoever gets this one.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to draw an actual... an actual pee-pee.
I didn't mean to, guys.
I swear.
It's just... it's just how the world works.
These are cursed postcards.
It's made with love.
Maybe we only label one to a hundred.
I don't know.
Stop giving...
We gotta be consistent.
No, you do the rest.
And don't use this one because it'll explode on you.
But I have to do my own.
Yeah, you'll just have to use the dry ones.
I'm sorry.
But I have to do my own.
Why can't you do this?
Because the pens don't work and I'm gonna have a fucking aneurysm.
You need a brain for that.
Yeah, it's leaking out my nose because of this.
It's not coming out.
Oh, no.
Wait, it is sort of.
It's not.
That's just how it was in the middle already.
Because it's metallic.
I think you gotta get, like, alcohol then...
Maybe... did you do the other side?
It's on this side, though.
Yeah, but then it leaked onto the other side, though, didn't it?
Yeah, so maybe do the other side, too.
But it's wet on the... it's going through.
Oh, man.
There might not be enough alcohol in it.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Soak it in sanitizer.
The... will probably come out after washing.
Oh, it says soak it in sanitizer or...
I can't soak it.
It's my pants.
When you... when you get home.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I mean, it should... it wouldn't matter if it dries up anyway if you're gonna soak it after.
I think you have to soak it immediately, right?
You have to soak it immediately, guys?
Do you guys have to soak it immediately?
We gotta know.
Yeah, we have to know.
Uh... oh, soak immediately.
Yeah.
Apparently.
Maybe ask your mom to buy you another one.
When she comes back.
She lives there.
Oh, wait, she lives there?
Yeah.
Oh.
That's cool.
Does she always live there?
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
I'm depressed.
Oh, wait, wait, really?
She always lived in...
She always lived in Japan?
Yeah.
Oh, my God, no wonder you're like this.
She's on her bed now.
She's... she's sad.
Guys, say some words to cheer her up.
She's... she can't read it because she's not at the chat.
I have to read them out.
I am signing the postcards.
Do you want me to sign?
Now I have to do the metallic ones too.
The numbers too.
Yeah, I have to also.
Oh, my God, don't do this to me.
Don't do this to me.
Someone says, You can do it.
And that's the two I'll read because I have to work now.
I'm almost done with my autographs.
Guys, she's depressed.
She's very sad right now.
She's on her bed watching TikToks.
I'm not... you know I'm not watching TikToks.
She's literally... she's...
She's watching TikToks instead of, you know, helping out, you know?
I did my job!
I'm not good enough, really.
All right, fine!
Fine, entertain chat!
Do it!
Go!
Oh, wait, I should go.
Yes!
I'm going!
Okay!
We're ending stream!
End our friendship!
Oh, wait, let me finish this first.
Oh, my God.
Are you actually done?
No, I'm not.
Of course I'm not!
Well, take them back to your room.
Oh, my God, what?
Yeah, because you have to finish!
Can you please do it?
No!
That's not even going to be all of them.
You just have to sign 100 of them.
To 200.
Guys, she kicked me out, guys.
Yeah, good night, everybody.
Guys, she kicked me out.
Good night, everybody.
Guys, she kicked me out, everybody.
Have a good night!
Yay to Christmas!
Guys, it's not you!
The reason why I'm leaving is not because of you guys.
Well, I mean, it kind of is because we're signing these for them.
Guys, I would never blame you guys.
We're going to take all your Sharpies and all your pens and everything.
Sometimes you might see me in the weekends.
But it's not... what happened to us is not because of you guys, though.
Okay, everybody.
Two birthdays!
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I'm getting hang... not hangry.
I'm getting sleepy-angy.
I'm sleepy-angy.
Okay!
Alright, well, bye, guys!
Bye!
We're going to finish this up.
See you guys later!
Bye!
Oh, you want the bag?
Wait, here, so put them in the bag and take the tote.
Okay, wait, can you...
Okay.
Wait, can they still hear us?
Yeah.
Okay, good, okay.
See, we're working together!
No, because this is not... this is numbered, and this is not...
These aren't numbered?
These aren't numbered.
These aren't numbered, so I have to number these.
And then these are the ones that I have to finish signing.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Um... how do we separate this?
I don't know.
Here, I'll just take them back...
There's bags here.
Yeah.
So you put...
I'll put the numbered one in the bag.
Yeah.
Put the numbered one in the bag.
You can keep these, because, like...
No, I'm not... we should give them...
You see them first.
I'll just give this to you.
I'll just go to your room and give this to you after I'm done.
And then you can give this...
I'm going to be asleep!
And I'm going to leave before you.
You're going to be asleep?
Yeah, but you'll see them first.
You give them this first.
Yeah, but when are you going to give these to me?
When I... no, as in, I'll give these to them when I see them.
No, I think we should just do it all together.
Okay, you won't be asleep instantly when I'm done.
Are you going to go to bed instantly?
How long are you going to be?
Wait, what time is it?
Oh, yeah, never mind.
Okay, I'll... yeah, I'll...
No, no, no, that's wrong.
My computer...
No, no, no, I know, but I can... I can do math for now.
I...
Wait, what time is it?
No, no, I'll give...
Yeah, no, I'll give them... I'll give them to...
I'll give them to...
It's only the... but it's still...
Yeah, but you have...
Yeah, I know.
No, you're... you have to.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, so we figured it out.
Yeah.
You know what?
We should have done that off-screen.
Okay.
Bye.
This brings it to our lives.